hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to bendy and the dark
Revival we are in a strange room where
we was told to go to sleep by getting
some drugs and I don't know about you
wait Gilson mix everything in a glass
and then drink it exactly with three
sips of water
I don't know where to find Gilson
I don't quite remember give me a moment
to channel into the back of my mind
okay I
item forward please
foreign
this place looks like it might have
Gilson a theory about spaces oh let us
imagine a long wire stretching between
two points in known time we will call
this length of time the euphonic Bass
from here we can dispel all needs of
societal normalcy and typically
understand Junctions of the world we
know as the present once the euphonic
bases achieved it creates a shared
understanding that there must be a space
around the wire that is not the wire
itself the space the commonly vacuum
move could be a
could be in itself a host of many wires
running in many directions that we can
perceive using a vessel of flow and flux
break we can escape from our wire to
another wire this allows us to not just
reveal the alternate time skates but
command them in a larger understanding
of their existence Firth is still in
theory we can bring the elements of one
world into another displace matter into
a new state regardless of the current
host wires rules and reality and
function of the elements becomes a new
euphonic base
well I understood all of that I don't
know about any of you
nothing here well yeah nothing but crap
this theories are bunk how about
fisherman Jeb's fish guide
if you found yourself looking for a hard
fighting fish that won't rip your hands
you should look further than the common
yellow perch this freshwater fish is
always quick to bite anything that they
can get their jaws on the best way to
get yourself one is to work your bait
worms minnows or larvae towards the
bottom of the water and guide your line
back up you don't need much seasoning
when it comes to cooking either the
flavor of the yellow perch is built
right in good oh here we go
this one is a little strange little fish
that is pretty hard to come by the
Gilson is not known to be easy to catch
and will ignore most bait to make
matters worse the Gilson can move very
fast making the rear sight in the end I
was able to snatch me up a little guy
with a very clever solution apparently
in the Gilson is sensitive to sound
vibrations and will go into shock upon
hearing some sweet music so crank up the
tunes and this fish should be easy to
grab crush up the Gilson into powder and
stir into water for a powerful soothing
drink
so
yeah apparently
uh uh if you're in a hurry Saucy cheese
buddies recipe chocolate bacon soup
there's gotta be one here somewhere
uh-huh well I don't know what anything
is around here somewhere
I don't know why there would be anything
around here somewhere
oh Gilson
Gilson
oh oh
Gilson that's a fish I think you need
good job give me you yeah it's too fast
oh he's too
I better play some good old-fashioned
music
oh
maybe if it was closer you're right this
is a good idea
they wouldn't mind this at all would
they they wouldn't care I wouldn't care
I don't care
get ready for it
[Music]
looks like the fish is asleep is it oh
it's dead no it's asleep no I might be
dead
wow I got it get away from me little
stinker I'm gonna grind
hello I uh I forgot the Gilson again
didn't I
and there's some already ground up in
the kitchen too uh um I'll be uh I'll
bring it up to your room straight away
shall I
oh and uh maybe you could put Harold
back in his tank
he does so hate the dry air
oh she's gone
I'm going back to bed don't worry pretty
cool about how I got that fish though
pretty pretty pretty dang cool there we
go pretty dang cool if you ask me oh
ah how why is it so important that I
fall asleep and why should I fall asleep
I don't even know about this three sips
of water
or else I go to sleep forever
[Applause]
now just three sips of water
a one one
weird why are they doing this
three three
four
oh my God
for safety
[Music]
you've gotta dine inches
it's not every day one gets to bask in
the glory
oh you're welcome
[Music]
to imperfection
what do you want
all right to the cheese I like that the
truth is
you're one of a kind and to put it
bluntly what I want
is your face removed your skin peels
away like paper and your insides torn
out and tossed onto my table
TS ready for my delicious heart
okay and with your generous sacrifice
beautiful
but for now let's have fun plenty of
time for a blood bath later plenty of
meat idea
[Music]
no
all right here's the deal
behind you is the door to Freedom okay
but it will only be opened if you solve
my little puzzle and return to your
special chance
special dare I'll throw this
head switch if you get the puzzle right
you walk away
get it wrong
I see
all right I actually didn't catch any of
that I was too enamored by your
beautiful dining chair and the lovely
dining Arabs in
so uh
how you doing the fox thinks the rabbit
smells of Elderberry I couldn't see them
sitting together
well that's a weird thing to say usually
people say hello hi my name is
Markiplier I'm a YouTuber anyway uh the
bird won't have anything to do with the
rabbit but I hear he likes to court
danger by sitting next to the fox
weather's nice too yeah uh-huh
what was the battery refill I've never
even seen that be used
um
[Music]
she'll never find me
all right
okay I gotta do some puzzle I get it so
what I'm gathering from this is that
there's some kind of a doodad or up here
with probably paintings that I gotta
rearrange in a specific order
because it's fun
uh only four huh
interesting
monkey
did anybody say anything about a monkey
all right can I get that one more time
and I'm really gonna turn my brain on
for this
[Music]
company
rabbit smells of Elderberry I couldn't
see them sitting together rabbit is away
from the fox the fox has always hated
the bear
hey never sit next to each other Fox no
like bear friend the bear always sits
next to the bird after all they went to
school together I mean this seems fairly
simple but I might be dumb
so if I'm not mistaken the fox is over
here whoop
the bird is over here the bear is here
because they went to school together I
think that's a bear and then the rabbits
over here
probably
did I get it
all right let's see what happens I have
full confidence
I have 100 confidence let's do this
put me in coach Hold On Tight honey
here it comes
three two
one
oh
[Music]
well maybe you shouldn't have rigged it
up so that everyone would die instead of
me and I I'm guessing you're not dead
but anyway you shouldn't have made your
puzzle so simple
you'll never vote what was that dangling
in there
oh it's just a column I thought it was
dangling okay well that was really fun
um wow that's ravetastic that's super
cool
see me where
I don't poop you don't know that this is
super cool the most colorful thing I've
seen in here
very nice actually
full charge gent pipe required
all right where can I oh
[Music]
and then I will event oh I don't have my
pipe do I didn't they ah convenience
that is extraordinarily convenient
what the hell whoa hey hey easy easy
all right stop it stop it stop it I'm
gonna die oh my God give me your bones
well that was unnecessary I don't know
if I have an upgrade do I have an
upgrade oh I can't
okay
well that was unfortunate dream Supply
what do you mean
that's food don't take food
there you go
can I charge this up please
[Music]
all right well
stick soccer day into whole B don't hit
the thing yeah
I did it what did I did
now weirdly it seemed like I powered it
down but if I knew what I was doing that
I would think that I would be putting a
charge thing in there to Power It Up
which is not what happened also I've
completely forgotten how to actually use
this thing's charged attack so I
probably could have gotten out of that
last situation with a little more Health
but I didn't
I did not what do I do oh wait there's a
ladder
man how do I
Go tab activates that that's interesting
I forget how to do my teleportation it
wouldn't be uh wow
that's how it happens well I suppose I
can
hey Alice angel I just saw you
whoa Alice angel I just saw you oh
[Music]
a gun
I didn't hurt at all
[Music]
so uh
you're still gonna be shooting or you we
peekaboon huh
oh God
oh
well I'll just climb then don't worry
about me
definitely wasn't insane when you were
climbing maybe you should come over here
good thing I charged this and good thing
I'm
immutable it's apparently
I reek of egg demon
I don't even know what that means I
don't know what this does I'm gonna open
it
oh there's two locks okay duly noted
[Music]
well you're already beautiful on the
inside whoa interesting
well uh Temper Temper whatever shut up
take this oh my God
take
this
oh God oh God oh God oh God yo
I was stealing the spotlight you never
had the spotlight in the first place
more trash talk
I don't even know who you are
I can do this all day uh
uh okay
what did I just do again I've completely
forgotten what I just did in there
oh I charged up my pipe that's what I
did okay so I need to find the other oh
you didn't see anything
can I make that let's see Yo oh god oh
okay this I've got too much dabbling
cow well this is going to be problematic
if I don't
make this
yeah
whoa whoa whoa you could see me
holy crap
that's nice can I get there I don't know
let's find out
don't push me into the line of fire
whatever you do
okay so I've already been up there and I
already did that and I need to go up
there
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
ouch
all right
that's good to know I'm really proud of
you
I could go in this door
and then I can do this thing where does
she go
hey what's that coffee
that does sound pretty good honestly
come for coffee delicious
all right
[Music]
Bo shut up
Wherever You Are
shut up
can you say new things
oh yeah where does she go
can I just consume you can I use my
special ability upon you
all day I'm gonna banish you get slurped
I didn't do it yet
oh geez
[Music]
let's blow them away
ah
my face
out of my face
our face
I'm beautiful
always were
[Music]
why does this feel so familiar
are you all right Audrey Alice I cannot
begin to tell you how good it is to see
you
and this hello
Audrey meet Tom
he's my protector hi my friend
you both got here just in time
now I understand why you don't like
being called Alice the machine creates
many of the same forms
at least on the outside
we're all pretty different well from now
on I'm going to call you something other
than Alice
just doesn't suit you didn't she have a
nickname already what do you have in
mind
how about
Allison
it's not bad
okay I'll try it out I'm renaming you
only if you can tell me what in Heaven's
name you're doing in Wilson's Retreat
Wilson I almost forgot I have to get
back right away are you crazy Wilson's
our enemy do you even know him have you
ever talked to him
seen what he's done
it's good enough for me look it sounds
like he has a plan to kill the ink demon
for good and
I think he can help us all I just
I just need to go back and hear him out
both need us
but ink demon won't go down without a
fight
Tom and I will gather some of our
friends
anyone who's left
good luck Audrey man I'm two hours my
Charisma must be just 20. I I changed
this person's name I made their whole
belief system turn on a dime I am just
the most compelling speaker in the world
I almost said speak person but that
would have been right I'm biting
for find me
anyway
so Tom uh
I don't know about that one I don't like
this I don't like this at all I don't
like that I hated that
I hate I bet you because that would be
just as awkward ah weird don't like that
didn't like that none and I hated that
actually
hmm
not right
beautiful people run this world if you
can have brains or Talent you may just
sneak through the gates but with a
pretty face every door opens the crowd
bows to you they ask your name they want
you to attend they ask you to speak a
silky voice with gorgeous lips as
everyone's weak spot
I was reborn with my perfection stolen
from me to get it back I'll rip this
rotted World apart angels are beautiful
angels are beautiful all right sure
I believe you I mean I guess
that's probably not foreshadowing
that's probably fine
well time to hear Wilson out I guess
I'm dying
I can't really understand you through
your phlegm if you could clear
what is happening good morning
don't moan stop moaning cease your moans
oh Powers have been disabled
I don't know how you do that but you're
doing it and I don't like it
I'll have to climb the old-fashioned way
without falling and breaking my ankles
every time
God what a world what torture this is
what a horrible experience this must be
for me
you okay
everything good down here well since I'm
going back to talk to Wilson I would
figure that they would still be on my
side because those are Wilson's like
turvans right
hey
I jumped down
yes I can
ow my ankles
ah sustenance
I have been Reborn
Peak I don't want to peek
hide I'll wait for it to go by and then
I will
Traverse the hallway of death
[Music]
pretty close right I'm actually
surprised I've never done a voice like
that before my plan is
coming to fruition
soon it will be time to move out this
fool
is stupid and dumb with dumb tentacle
legs it's time you are a wire all right
whatever that voice hurts my throat wait
did I need to do this I don't even know
if I needed to
hey y'all
I don't know if I can get to that other
hiding spot before it turns around and
then it would see me when I'm over there
but I'm gonna go for it
good bad idea
I will hide in here I'm not gonna do
that anymore that really would hurt your
voice well this is a oh there was a hand
oh it's a door
I'm dumb did you guys know that I'm dumb
I'm dumb I'm a stupid idiot
I've never been more idiotic you know if
you patrolled just the tiniest bit
faster you'd be more likely to find me
I'm just gonna say that just so you know
don't listen to this
don't listen to that oh listen don't
hear it good
that's more like it
dream Supply I don't need it what are
you I don't know if you'll read these
notes but I'll keep leaving them for you
I hope someday you'll understand my
words in the madness will fade from your
mind in the strange and dark place we
can find light and purpose we are not
left to wander alone craving Beauty
power and other meaningless things even
the heart of someone feeling in complete
can discover Joy we're not lost we're
merely waiting to be found we are so
much alike formed from the same mold
we're like sisters you and me I wish you
comfort and wisdom to let your heart
melt into happiness I won't give up
trying to reach you before it's too late
oh that's very sweet but you stabbed her
through the
back
this music box could make a good
distraction if I can fix it
I'm not following
I don't know what you mean
all right fix the music spots how do I
do that hey you got anything
dummy
how about you
so what do I need
if I can fix it yes I can although
sneaking around does work you know
I am very good at that I'm good at the
sneaking thing
why doesn't that one squeak
they said he killed my Lord they said
the ink demon fell they said I was a
false prophet but I say my Lord lives I
say he will return but I say you better
watch your back Mr Wilson can I get an
amen
who are you talking to thanks for the
bacon soup
chocolate bacon soup
where did he go
where did she go I don't know
I'm falling
well try try that again
I hear you
where are you
here at the Lock
um
walls partitions
still nothing
where you coming from
where you going whoo what do you got
there
oh that looks like something I could fix
that music box with
maybe so uh what you doing
and also what's it oh oh oh I didn't
notice that before I've got a signal
I've got a landmark
and if I can only get to it surely I can
find my way to something that can fix a
music box that's what I've tuned my
sixth sense to anyone there
better not be better not be right around
the corner you better not be right
around the corner you better numb you
best not be I'm gonna hide I'm gonna
hide oh hi hi hide in that damn thing
that was close
good thing I took advantage of that
opportunity everybody
that could have gone very poorly for me
I don't know if there's another one over
here this is
this why did I come down here
okay
perfect this will fix it it's not the
piece that was missing
it'll fix it it's good God damn ow my
bones my Inky bones can I fix it now
this isn't gonna what it's gonna oh I'm
charged up but but I thought oh there's
probably oh
fine
fine I guess okay so it's got to be over
here this other one does
well that's peculiarly time gated
don't hear my bones and my scream can I
have this can I have this can I have any
of this can I have any of this did you
do this why'd you do this this is really
mean where are you going where are you
going where you going
where you going
oh [__] I charged my thing
I don't know if it's still gonna be
charged oh yes
oh open please open quickly oh open nope
open open open
I'm in oh God how many of you are
why are there so many
oh that doesn't sound good oh that's bad
uh
where you going where you going you
coming down here going all the way down
you are
good thing you're an idiot
What the freaking what oh my God please
tell me no
oh
okay well that was nice that's all the
pieces for the music box I found the
last piece for the thing I'll distract
them with you ever listen to my podcast
distractible that's all it does it just
plays distractible on Loop in Mass oh
nice jury
[Music]
oh I should hurry
don't listen to this don't don't do it
it's a good thing they're deaf
oh my God okay wait a minute whoa wait
there's no need that there's no need
oh there's no need
where am I I think it teleport
I think it teleported me to somewhere
that I want to be and what are you doing
over there
yes it's me whatever my name is
how do I get down
good luck to me
why is it thumpity thump why thumpity
Thump Thump why I gotta fix a thing
with my brains or whatever
okay good
Ness
I think I know where to do that where
those two were guarding the thing
definitely is probably the right place
to be for this definitely probably
oh how do I get up I don't even know oh
shoot y shoot my duty oh my Tooties
what does this do I don't know
let's find out
I don't know what that did
hmm
well this is concerning
they're gonna see me
but I guess if I let them see me and
then go aroundy I I guess oh
I don't have any other marker to dictate
whether or not this would be a good idea
here I go oh it's me oh my God
holy crap I'm dead I'm so dead oh I'm
dead
all right well that was not good turns
out they understand you can go two ways
about these things
um
where could I put this
there was that dead body but I doubt
that they would care about that would
they
would they care is this a good place for
it
sure doesn't seem like it where uh
because I definitely see that this is
probably where I'm supposed to do this
and the Tesla Tower is down so I have my
powers
so I'm not exactly sure what the problem
is
oh well I'm down
oh oh easy of course it was so obvious
and I run like hell and not move so
goddamn slow
[Laughter]
what a wonderful
distraction can you trim this and I was
like well I thought I had an hour and a
half before yeah
[Laughter]
don't listen to this don't listen to
this don't listen to this
any goodies I should probably focus on
the lock though
do these
oh yes tasty treats can't be Beats
okay I'm free I did it I done did it I
did it I did it
I did it
oh
do you know that it was horrible down
there
did you know that hello there you are
thank goodness Wilson's waiting for you
downstairs in the laboratory when you're
ready but first can I get your help with
something
then why'd you just twitch I didn't like
that what do you mean what do you mean
normally I wouldn't ask this of a guest
uh-huh with all that's happening I can't
sneak out and get things like I usually
do mm-hmm you think you could pop Brown
to the farmer's market back in town and
find me a few ingredients we're running
quite low in the kitchen and I was
hoping we could all celebrate tonight
with a lovely supper won't take but a
moment if you go by train up to you no
pressure
the travel take the train the next train
is always on to ower
he seems like a strange side quest to go
about but okay are there Farmers here
you want me to go to the farmer's market
I'm
not a hundred percent sure
what you mean by that
I know it sounds crazy but
I don't think there are Farms
in ink land
oh
here there where here there other side
which side
oh
[Music]
okay wait for me
interesting
[Music]
okay great why all right whatever
Farmers Market yee-haw Wilson can wait
screw all that I gotta eat chocolate
bacon soup out of the trash can
yippee
oh
whoa hey a toolkit
man the farmer's market you gotta love
it
God I love it
I don't know where the farmer's market
is
oh yield farmer oh
this this is it where's Betty's
ingredients
oh for Betty ooh live finger what
I don't know I don't get it I don't get
it but sure I got it buddy
don't you worry
I got it hello here's your ingredients
Mom you're a miracle worker truly oh I
only wish there was something I could do
for you oh wait I spotted something in
the fountain yesterday don't know what
it's for but you're welcome to have it
you better go see Wilson downstairs he's
been waiting ages yeah I wonder why what
did you get me
did you give me something
what did you give me
what did you give me spotted in the
fountain oh do I have to oh I have to
get it
so sad
um
thanks
guys it's a Spaceman where's the bay you
never pointed it out to me
I came from there
but it looks like that'd be the basement
it really this goes down that's the only
down I know
that can't be because that's where I
came from so the South Wing has that or
the yeah the South Wing has to have a
basement of some kind right so am I
supposed to find it
Wilson knows your purpose uh since
Wilson's the only one walking down here
does Wilson really need this kind of
reassurance I mean self-affirmation is
one thing but
does seem a little silly
hey yo Wilson
okay
weird oh
wow
oh pretty
fun
well son hey oh wow
fascinating
[Music]
foreign
ah
oh ah so drab in here I'm depressed
I did yeah
okay
[Applause]
oh yeah
ominous
amanus
amanas
Among Us
yo what's up bud for coming all this way
the ink demon is a formidable foe
truly destroy such a monster he must be
dethroned
humiliated
for months now I've been working on
something that will do exactly that cast
out the demon and put a new deity in his
place
stronger more powerful and controllable
together
come let me show you my creation
but elegant
treasure powerful Beyond anyone
the Inked human will fall and we can
help you at last oh man Wilson no it
sounds risky look Wilson we don't want
to repeat Joey's mistake no we don't all
of the factors must be perfect the right
design the right science and
the right
and last your purpose is revealed are
three this is why you're here with your
soul inside in my creation will live
forever
stay away from me you're insane come now
descend
I thought you said we needed to save
your father I thought you had a plan to
send me home to make everything right
I lied my father is beyond hope
perhaps you know him Nathan Arch owner
of archgate industrial genius business
tycoon for years I've lived in his
reaching Shadow he always had time for
the grand creatives of the world the
doers as he called them he knew only the
best the biggest thinkers how could his
lonely son ever hope to compete with
that
but now
thanks to you
I can
no need to struggle my signal prevents
you from using those devilish powers of
yours and more importantly
he ain't demon from getting in
it's time to die Audrey and live again
but I don't want to be ship boy Dudley
hey
laughs
[Music]
I could dick with my legs not this time
oh wow what did I do differently
[Music]
he's gone oh never mind
yeah oh yeah
subject accepted oh boy
oh wow uh
uh ink machine Mark II oh boy well
anyway he's dead uh so
um
oh wait hold on hold on hold on with you
ah soup
and you I decided to go for a walk this
morning took a little stroll down to the
park
enjoyed the warm sun for a while found a
quiet bench you should grab the hot dog
I've done that because it would kill me
if she knew I've been off my diet and I
got back to the office I stopped by the
animation department and said hello to
the Troops my gosh they're getting
younger every day
either that or I'm just getting older it
all made me realize time is moving on
the hard struggles don't seems dire as
they used to
life has other value
I think
I'll go home early today
maybe I'll even pick up a hot dog for
Tessa
everybody loves a hot dog
you ain't lying about that I love Hot
Dogs everybody loves hot I love soup
it really does sound like I'm just just
gagging it down just like forking it as
hard as I can hork because surely it
can't be good for me hey where does this
go
where's [__] boy whatever his name was
ship boy Chips Ahoy
huh
oh
uh never mind I guess I can't go down
there
what I was the question am I supposed to
ask the question where did this come
from
yeah sure
I see a Leverage
[Music]
oh
boy
uh controllable yes I control you
foreign
I see what I'm supposed to do here
oh wait wait wait wait a minute hold on
I'm shutting this down somehow don't hit
me don't whoa whoa
I'm stabbing this in that's safe
oh what are you doing don't do it hit
this one
hit this definitely don't come and
attack me hit this
hit it hit it
hit it hit me
hey you were supposed to hit this
that was a close one
whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa oh whoa
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's
with the colors
oh yum yum yum a delicious yum hey whoa
hey what do you what do you think you're
doing hey hey stop that
hit me hit me I dare you what
get me over here let me let me I dare
you I dare you to
oh don't do it no that's not what I
wanted ow
stop it
oh that one caught me around the teeth
I'm not gonna lie that was a good throw
Yay good good good
idiot hey no miss me uh you hit me but
okay
okay all right more yes
wow it really kind of hurts sometimes
whoa hey whoa hey watch it watch it
watch it bud
get away from me
I State your friend what do you think
about that yeah yum whoa hey whoa yum
yum yum yum
I ate them what are you gonna do one
more oh shoot oh you almost got me oh
what
ah
okay what are you gonna do you big crab
[Music]
what oh I can zoom now oh
what are you doing
what are you doing stop it oh God
is this working oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh ow I'm gonna die
I'm dead I've been ripped in Twain
okay so what I'm gonna do this
okay all right oh you're not gonna go oh
boy hey
cause I'm gonna leave these guys a lot
dead I'm not gonna eat them yet whoa hey
temper and now you die you die you die
you die you die you die you die you die
you die okay now I've got a bunch of
bodies which is great
why is it great
you can't quite remember I don't know if
this is really doing oof
ouch okay well hey can I get a body or
um
sandwich okay
uh that was not food oh God oh God oh
God please please food food any of you
any of you food any any of you food
bendy bar
how do I uh Dodge that's my big question
I'm dead
how do I dodge I guess I gotta use my
zoopy do to get to the side of him okay
I think I seem to be doing well here a
little close for comfort
don't do it don't do it no you don't do
it
oh I didn't hear that you're very quiet
when you want to be extremely stealthy
so I seem to be doing a little better
no don't do it there we go
don't thrust your butt at me
whoa oh whoops
that's a good thing you're terrible at
this oh God you not as terrible as I
thought holy crap can I eat please give
me some food please okay something
something oh my God I am almost dead
holy [__]
oh I almost said I don't know
oh God no no no not again not again no
go go go go God damn it
damn you don't do it
I am so gonna die and it's gonna be so
sad
okay I don't really know how to dodge
this
[Applause]
oh hey wow did I do it
hi
did you rip my body in it what did you
oh you ripped my legs off
ow
foreign
[Music]
whoa was a terrorism
and your mistake
had a moment
light
me
not I make you strong
I will make you lose
time okay
foreign
[Music]
like the Lich King
huh
it's already like married or something
we like
betrothed or what's the deal
huh
[Music]
there's always a choice
I know you're in there
deep behind that evil face
inside somewhere is my little girl
my Audrey
my greatest creation
I'm scared I don't know what's happening
the past doesn't Define you
nor the present
in the end all those years ago Joey Drew
finally succeeded
he created life
but Audrey
you're so much more than that
yours family
his daughter
my daughter
and I love you so very much
remember
you are Audrey remember
dogs
it's never too late
isn't enough
you have to have
heart
the future I see
foreign
[Music]
this
is the end
[Music]
oh ah
cool
oh hell yeah oh okay I thought that was
gonna be cut to credits there I actually
get to do this now we're talking watch
take this and one of these and some of
this and one of these please
can I hit harder
I feel like this isn't as hard as I
could hit I feel like I could hit a lot
harder
oh I can just move through whoa whoa
whoa when did I do that did I do that
again oh wow all right that's nice man
you guys are pretty brave you know this
look at look at my ass strutting up the
way here wow
yeah I'm a monster yeah look at my
monsters
look at my incredible monstrous
you wish you could come back to my
gluteus
man me a cardboard
in the face of my Majesty
it's so funny it was so silly just the
walk there I can't even look at me from
the front who would want to with a
behind like this
oh this seems to be some mosquitoes
buzzing about
yeah
mm-hmm I'd like to leave one to tell the
rest to fear me
oh yeah
got any ink
just a stamping will do
excuse me I'm late for whatever the hell
I'm doing well
mm-hmm
hello
[Music]
Allison Audrey is that you in there
come on keep moving we'll get you
through Tom
make us some trouble hey
[Music]
who's that guy
good thing I fed him
[Music]
I'm running I think how can you trust
real good
mm-hmm
hello Daddy
all right I'm running I think I don't
know if this qualifies as running but
I'm moving at exactly the same was that
Rambo
what was that
keep fighting fighting
you want me to keep fighting demons
man you guys aren't really helping me
area
[Music]
it is you're right
like is this working for them are they
succeeding or
losing people in so many droves that
it's
almost unspeakable the losses that they
are experiencing
[Music]
oh I can run I can run I could have run
this whole time
oh interesting well this is much more
dramatic when I'm running it's just now
what
need some help who Henry
Henry oh
even a million times ah hey what's up I
found a projector of the head run for it
all right you got it
oh this body is mine apparently
well then we'll just have to do better
next time
hey wow
well that's convenient
uh the end
thank you
oh nice
[Applause]
[Music]
my father once told me
just because we're born of Darkness
doesn't mean we belong to it
we're always free to choose
tear
the very beginning
there's a choice to make
my father's cartoon world was now mine
to rule
to watch over and to protect
I can make the cycle more bearable for
my friends inside
but as for me
I'm the first of my kind
born of ink but living in flesh
Joey's world is escaping into
so what's next
who can really say
do you know why are you looking at me I
wouldn't know
I have no idea
well hey
there you have it
oh spooky
oh no Wilson
oh no Audrey
[Music]
it was good I think that the anything
that I could say about it is things that
people would already pick up
and there's no need to go too much into
them what I will say it suffered from
some things about gameplay uh mechanics
being introduced and then it's almost
like they had to be shoehorned in here
and there where they could be used the
boss fight did take the charging and
releasing mechanic and I did like that
the doors opening is like whatever and
they gave way too many batteries so that
you would never ever need even need to
use the battery recharge which is
probably only there as a Fail-Safe in
case it failed but also I never used the
ability to zap people with the Baton
because I needed it for all the doors
anyway but apparently I didn't need a
fully charged one there was many things
about the actual like game mechanics
that I think were a little clunky and
like the weird quests to go back and
forward
in the world
and I feel like in that spot there
should have been the maid there but the
maid wasn't there I did the maids side
quest too but all in all still it's
crafting up a whole universe and that's
tough to do for anybody and it's trying
to like build it out and be robust and
that's like really something to be proud
of when you're done uh and the game is
released and it's out there for everyone
to experience so I'd say from that
perspective well done like they did a
great job here I'm obviously a small
team working on it
and uh yeah
better than I've done and I've made a
game well thank you everybody so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed this
glad I could finish this and I will be
finishing all the other series that I
have started I promise you that thank
you and as always I will see you in the
next video
bye-bye
[Music]